ah non j'étais le reproducteur et le
malheureux producteur de deux des deux
derniers spectacles de de Pierre Palmade
21 octobre tu es à de hier ça se passe
merveilleusement bien il est adorable il
est prévenant il nous dit mais est-ce
que c'est ce qui il a dit je suis un il
a dit je suis un chic type et je crois
que c'est un chichage lui-même je suis
anti bien et c'est voilà c'est c'est le
les stupéfiants qui me rendent comme ça
donc pour un chips pour moi c'était
injecté parce que dès qu'on lui a
proposé il a dit mais évidemment si je
peux pas René des jeunes c'est génial et
cetera
21 octobre il nous prévient il nous dit
bon je sais que j'ai une mauvaise
réputation quelque part donc je suis pas
fiable donc je vous rassure
dès 15h 16h j'attends le taxi dans le
taxi nous renvoie un message pour dire
ça y est je suis dans le taxi une heure
avant d'arriver il arrive etc etc il
fait le spectacle mais merveilleusement
il y avait 1000 personnes c'était archi
combles les gens riait énormément et
quand il a vu qu'il y avait 1000
personnes dans la scène il me dit mais
ils viennent tous pour pour Palma là je
dis bah oui bien sûr c'était une star
quoi voilà mais tu vois bon j'ai intérêt
à les faire rire alors et donc le
spectacle se termine tout se passe
magnifiquement bien on le ramène en
voiture avec avec Mathieu vilaine qui
représente les soirées avec moi et là il
nous redit mais vous m'avez donné une
pêche ce soir je reprends goût à faire
le spectacle à faire du one man etc les
gens se marraient avec le Scrabble avec
ces tous ces sketchs c'était vraiment
super et on était super content on le
redépose à Paris aucun problème mais on
se dit on a donc une autre date qui est
au Théâtre des Mathurins
bon bah ça se passe bien vous décidez de
refaire une autre date forcément voilà
c'était magnifique c'était juste là le
15 janvier 2e date alors deuxième date
on lui propose donc on lui dit écoute on
fait aussi le théâtre des matures à
Paris quand même un théâtre prestigieux
en plus il était fan de Sylvie Joly qui
a fait ses adieux à des matures etc etc
donc il y avait un côté vraiment très
affectif dans cette dans cette dans
cette soirée et une lime évidemment je
viens envoyer moi quand même un petit
message trois jours avant pour me le
rappeler que je fasse pas de conneries
d'ici le spectacle parce que comme on
sait bien faire la fête longuement donc
on lui renvoie un petit message trois
jours avant il répond pas bon il faut
voir que le 15 janvier c'était quand
même le lendemain de la diffusion de la
fine équipe qui était sur France 2 qui
était un énorme succès on l'a vu et on
se dit bon bah à midi il répond pas donc
14h il répond pas comment ça s'inquiéter
un petit peu mais on se dit il a dû
fêter le le succès de l'émission 16h 17h
on réessaye mais c'est 50 fois de le
joindre 17h le téléphone décroche enfin
et on a Pierre Palmade qui fait au pire
alors c'est bon tu arrives machin et on
entend
et là répondeur jusqu'au soir qu'est-ce
que tu veux faire au public qu'est-ce
que tu veux leur dire est-ce que tu
avais commandé
400 7 puisque c'était complet
évidemment qu'est-ce qui dit au public
et donc qu'est-ce qu'on dit au public à
ce moment-là tu vois bah on peut pas
vous dire qu'il est malade parce qu'il
va peut-être arriver d'une minute à
l'autre pour faire le show et nous bon
15 jours après on se met Mathieu
Madénian donc j'ai à la fin du spectacle
j'ai dit Pierre Palmade ne répond pas au
téléphone il ne vient pas
on vous invite tous à la soirée avec
Mathieu Madénian donc bon c'était mis un
peu le public dans la poche grâce à ça
et le lendemain on reçoit un texto de
pierre
nous disons je crois que j'ai envoyé
d'ailleurs je suis honteux de vous avoir
fait ce sale coup hier soir je suis en
ce moment dans une période où ma
toxicomanie détruit ma vie et j'étais
dans l'incapacité de prévenir et encore
moins de venir je suis vraiment désolé
vraiment triste et j'espère que vous
avez pu gérer votre spectacle quand même
toutes mes excuses pierres là quand on
dit ça on se dit on se dit c'est ça
résume ça résume tout exactement et on
se dit il a besoin d'un exorcisme il en
parle comme s'il était possédé en fait
la toxicomanie me pourrit ma vie c'est
pas bon bah j'ai pris un petit truc non
c'est me pourrie ma vie
c'est épouvantable ce texto
il dit il dit la vérité il dit
exactement ce sms il est il est
incroyable donc il a su mais totalement
son problème et euh qu'est-ce que vous
êtes dit en voyant ça vous le verrez
répondu ben si on était très très en
colère le le 15 au soir parce que bon
nous c'est aussi un peu notre
crédibilité on était au Théâtre des
Mathurins de Mathurins ont l'habitude de
voir l'invité centrale pas venir ou en
tout cas pas prévenir il aurait pu être
malade il aurait pu envoyer un message
je suis souffrant désolé on trouver une
date non donc on était très en colère et
quand on reçoit ça on se dit le enfin
excusez-moi mais un peu le pauvre
non parce qu'on a fait le spectacle
quand même sans lui on a été on a perdu
du coup sur le spectacle d'après ce
qu'on a invité la salle à venir voir ma
Dénia donc c'était un peu vous l'avez
demandé des des choses des dommages
alors déjà ils nous ont envoyé son son
micro on attendait qu'il vienne faire
ses essais de micro de trucs et on
voyait qu'il arrivait pas demander des
dommages internes pas du tout non non
d'accord
fait jusqu'au bout donné aussi où on
peut aussi regarder
on fait pas le procès exactement
tu viens récupérer ton micro je veux te
voir en personne quoi et c'était voilà
son accident c'est le mois suivant il a
pas il a pas réagi
c'est pour ça que je disais j'étais
heureux et malheureux producteur parce
que d'un côté ça c'était tellement bien
passé qu'on avait qu'une seule envie
c'était lui dire viens on te donne les
Mathurins à un soir machin il était
super content et la deuxième c'était une
catastrophe quoi donc